[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: And go.
[BEEP]
You know what this timer means?
Every quarter
second a user spends
staring at a blank screen
instead of interfacing
with your app is a
quarter second more
they're willing
to close your app
and give their attention
to something else.
[BEEP]
My name is Colt McAnlis,
and misunderstanding
all the complex things that
happen during your app startup
can lead to some serious
performance problems.
Now, see, Android
is pretty smart
when it comes to understanding
human performance perception.
As soon as the user
launches your application,
Android will immediately
display a start window, which
will stay around until your
application is fully loaded,
initialized, and can
draw its first frame.
This behavior is
most often seen when
your app is booted
for the first time,
but it can easily happen
other times as well,
like when the activity is
brought to the foreground,
or after the user
backs out of your app,
or after some
portion of your app
has been purged by the
system to save memory.
Basically, any time the user
moves from something else
to your application,
there's a chance
you can see this
type of behavior.
The important
point here is this.
Letting the user spend too
much time looking at the start
window gives them
ample opportunity
to get bored and move
on to other things.
And taking too long
in general could even
cause the Application Not
Responding dialog to pop up.
Neither of these are very
good for user retention.
So from the technical
side, the whole process
works something like this.
When the user launches your app,
the system does a bit of work
to load your
application information
and create a unique
process for your app.
From there, the
system process will
display the starting
window and basically
hang out until the
application is up and running.
Meanwhile, the
application process
will create the
application object
and launch the main thread.
This is where your
startup activity
will be initialized, created,
inflated, and finally drawn.
It's only at this point,
after the application
has drawn its first frame,
that the system process then
goes and swaps out the start
window for the application.
Now, to be clear, the majority
of that entire process
happens pretty cleanly.
There's not really much
chance that performance
can go off the rails.
However, there are
three big areas
where things could
become problematic
that you should keep an eye on.
The first thing you should
really take a look at
is all the work that goes into
creating your activity class.
Most often, there's
lots of heavy lifting
that occurs during this
process, but heaviest
has to be the inflation
of layouts and loading
of resources that
goes along with it.
This is not a cheap process, and
if your layouts are too complex
or you've got some
blocking logic in there,
this can cause some
really big problems.
On a similar note, make sure you
take a look at your application
initialization.
For really complex
apps, the initialization
of the app object often
becomes a junk drawer
for lots of global
classes that might
be used between activities.
So there tends to
be lots of work here
that could be deferred
to later times
or perhaps loaded in
a lazy-load fashion.
Now, there's lots of
applications out there
which provide custom
start windows.
This is either
done to help brand
the application or
to make a slow load
look like a custom-branded
application.
Now, if you're doing this
to hide bad load times,
obviously, you should
fix that first.
But if you're doing
it for branding,
then you need to be aware that
there's a right and a wrong way
to set this up, so that it
doesn't influence the user
perception too negatively.
But before you run
off into the weeds
and try to fix these
types of common patterns,
you need to sit
down and figure out
if you have a problem
in the first place.
Thankfully, Android has
a few tools to help.
Firstly is display time.
For releases after
KitKat, Logcat
will include an
output line which
displays the amount of time
between when the process was
launched and the activity
finally drawn to the screen.
This can be helpful,
because it gives you
a general idea how long it takes
to occur for your application.
Oh, by the way,
note, if you want
to see this value inside
of Android Studio,
you need to turn off filters
for the Logcat output.
So keep that in mind.
Secondly is
reportFullyDrawn function.
The displayed metric
that's reported in Logcat
is useful for most
situations where
you'd like to track
down the time it
takes to go from application
start to first visible.
However, in modern
application development,
there's often a great deal
of lazy loading-- that is,
rather than blocking the
initial drawing of the window,
asynchronously loading resources
and views in the background
and updating the view
hierarchy accordingly.
The result is that while
the initial activity may
be visible, it may not yet
be fully loaded with respect
to resources, which
could be considered
a separate metric to use
when evaluating launch time
performance.
To address this concern,
you can manually
call the
activity.reportFullyDrawn
function to let the system know
that your activity is finished
with its lazy loading.
Third is method tracing.
While display time
and reportFullyDrawn
give a good understanding
of the overall load
time of your application,
they do not provide details
into what may be
causing particular parts
of that pipeline to go
longer than expected.
To gain more insight
in this area,
you can use the
start method tracing
tool inside of Android Studio.
And finally is the
big one, Systrace.
When you add trace
functions inside
of your onCreate methods, it
will augment your logging,
such that the Systrace
tool can properly
discover all the
subsections and display them
in its graphing process.
And if you're looking for more
great performance insight,
don't forget to check out
the rest of the "Android
Performance Patterns" content.
And be sure to join the Google+
community to ask questions from
other perf gurus.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]